c'était il ya 60 ans le 5 juillet 1962
132 ans jour pour jour après la
colonisation de l'algérie par la france
l'algérie devient indépendante des
milliers d'algériens sortent dans les
rues brandissant leurs drapeaux pour
célébrer leur indépendance
un jour de fête pour les algériens un
jour de deuil pour les français
d'algérie qui quittent massivement le
pays où ils étaient installés depuis des
générations 60 ans après les plaies sont
toujours ouvertes de part et d'autre et
la réconciliation reste très difficile
de nombreux dossiers attendent encore
d'être traités parmi lesquels celui des
disparus de la guerre d'algérie le
dossier des essais nucléaires de reggane
autant de sujets que nous aborderons
avec nous invité l'historien gilles
manceron le réalisateur algérien djaâfar
gassem et notre reporter karim yahoo
mais d'abord ces images du défilé
militaire à alger à l'occasion du 60e
anniversaire de l'indépendance des
événements prévus pour l'occasion
aujourd'hui le président algérien
démérité bouna a prononcé un discours
avant le coup d'envoi du défilé
militaire à ses côtés des invités entre
autres le président tunisien kaïs aide
le président de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas le président congolais
denis sassou n'guesso
on va tout de suite vous présenter nos
invités sur ce plateau alors bon soir
gilles manceron vous êtes historien je
le disais spécialiste du colonialisme et
auteur de nombreux ouvrages sur
l'algérie merci d'être avec nous ce soir
sur ce plateau pour parler de cet
anniversaire djaâfar gassem réalisateur
algérien venu à paris présenter son film
héliopolis un film qui revient sur les
massacres du 8 mai 45 et puis karim
rihawi notre grand reporter qui a traité
de nombreux dossiers sur cette histoire
d'algérie si compliqué j'aimerais
d'ailleurs commencé avec vous un karim à
ces images de fait qu'on a vu celle de
62 et celle d'aujourd'hui 60 ans après
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire alors
c'est un défilé militaire impressionnant
ça faisait de très nombreuses années
qu'ils avaient pas d eu un défilé d'une
telle ampleur 33 ans je crois
c'est finalement une façon de réancrer
l'algérie dans cette légitimité
politique qui s'est construite depuis
toujours sur cette lutte pour
l'indépendance le parti s'appelle le
front de libération nationale encore
aujourd'hui et c'était face finalement
une façon de rappeler que cette
légitimité politique s'est construite
dans la lutte pour l'indépendance alors
ce 5 juillet on l'a vu c'était un jour
de c'est un jour d'ailleurs de
célébrations mais aussi de mémoire
gilles manceron le 5 juillet c'est la
dette officielle de l'indépendance de
l'algérie elle et c'est une date
symbolique également je le disais c'est
la date de la conquête de l'algérie 5
juillet 1830 on parle beaucoup de cette
guerre d'indépendance qui a duré sept
ans mais en parle finalement très peu de
cette période coloniale est ce que ce
n'est pas compliqué de dissocier les
deux est ce que ce n'est pas aussi la
raison pour laquelle il ya autant de
difficulté de faire ce rapprochement
avec la france oui évidemment il faut
relier les deux la période de la guerre
d'indépendance nationale algérienne ça a
été la dernière phase de la colonisation
française mais ça a été une phase
particulièrement violente il y à des
régions rurales d'algérie où pour la
première fois
les paysans les autochtones ont vu des
français et c'était des militaires en
armes alors qu'ils n'avaient pas jusqu'à
présent
aucun et donc
c'est une période qui s'ancre qui
s'enchaînent avec la période de la
colonisation
132 en tout c'est une période très
longue et très très douloureuse pour le
peuple algérien qui en a une mémoire
forte et on l'a vu d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup d'algériens raconte l'histoire
de leurs propres familles de leur oncle
de leur tante morts ou qui ont combattu
pendant pendant cette période donc ça
touche effectivement
les algériens dans leur propre famille
alors djaâfar gassem dans votre film
héliopolis donc que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure vous vous revenez sur les
prémices des massacres de sétif de
guelma et de rabat a est le nom de ce
qu'il voulait c'est d'ailleurs le nom de
la ville de guelma où des environs on va
regarder un extrait de votre fils et on
en parle juste après
la baisse ou les élus à miramont qui
manage
un sur le même combat maintenant même
tête enseignants nouvellement l'homme
qui réconcilie les indigènes aviva
france
même qui complotent oui batta domine une
chicha
[Musique]
mon père
la france outre à nouveau monde
je t'ai une grande nation
attendre tard fermement avait lu devant
la montée en puissance des musulmans
[Musique]
la vérité
c'est tout
provocation plus les portes vers
l'assimilation
la naissance d'une nation génial
tu n'as pas gagné c'est hi-fi
il ya des marches
qu'est ce que tu vas faire tu va les
tuer c'est ça ou bertrand
eux ou nous
pour ted
dehors la chasse au sahara fait rage
avec une violence tu peux pas imaginer
c'est tout
tout ce secteur
alors djaâfar gassem on a vu cet extrait
on voit que ça se déroule en 45 avant
les massacres de sétif un événement
majeur qui s'est déroulé juste avant
enfin quelques années avant le
déclenchement de la guerre
d'indépendance pourquoi vous avez choisi
cet événement
tout d'abord c'est un événement qui
n'est pas je veux dire c'est un des
événements les plus importants de
l'histoire de la révolution algérienne
de l'histoire de la colonisation aussi
française en algérie
car pour moi c'était un peu la goutte
d'eau qui avait débordé au passage il y
avait plein il y avait beaucoup de
conquêtes et de et de révolte et de et
de révolution à c'est-à-dire de de
bataille entre les musulmans et les
colons et l'armée française en
commençant par les conquêtes de l'émir
abdelkader et donc les événements de
8000 du mai 45 moi j'ai choisi guelma
mais bon c'est sétif guelma et kherrata
dans ma fiction c'était pour montrer que
quelque part en algérie quelque part
dans le monde où on fêtait
le monde fêter l'armistice la fin de la
deuxième guerre et qu'on algérie se
passer de douloureux événements dans le
constantinois est due à une
à des manifestations qui ont tourné au
drame à cause d'un drapeau algérien qui
a été agitée par un premier
indépendantiste agf anam jeunes scouts
algériens à sétif donc voilà donc pour
moi le film raconte d'abord les raisons
qui ont abouti aux événements qui
n'avons plus tard
engendré la guerre de révolution alors
on entend dans l'extrait qu'on a qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure
le terme l'assimilation c'est fini
est-ce que c'est aussi un point de
rupture gilles manceron oui je crois que
la période entre le débarquement des
alliés en novembre 42 en afrique du nord
qui a été suivie de combats
dans différents points de l'algérie
contre les autres entre les alliés
engagés contre les nazis et les
autorités le cas alain qui en fait la
guerre pourrait vite couru pour
combattre ce débarquement
à partir de là il ya une prise de
conscience des algériens et le 8 mai 45
que vous traitez dans votre film est un
épisode important de cette prise de
conscience puisque le drapeau algérien
est brandi
à à guelma à sétif aussi et a été
d'ailleurs brandi ailleurs le premier
mec une semaine avant à erbil dans
d'autres manifestations
mais où était aussi le les mains dans
d'autres voilà avec des répressions qui
n'ont pas eu la violence de celle de
sétif mais qui annonce quand même un
affrontement armé
majeur qui préfigure la guerre
d'indépendance nationale alors djaâfar
gassem ce film a été diffusé à travers
toute l'algérie il a été très bien
accueillie par par cette jeunesse qui
est qui est venu le voir est-ce que vous
appréhendiez cela
appréhender c'est difficile de le dire
mais je sais vous savez on a une
jeunesse qui a vite de l'histoire et
cinéma j'essaie de comprendre les deux
et ça a bien marché on a on a essayé de
proposer une fiction tout d'abord c'est
une histoire humaine avant toute chose
les unit c'est un film de contexte donc
on essayait de de traiter le film avec
un langage simple un parler assez simple
pour les jeunes pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre on n'a pas fait de 2,2 de
recherche documentaire pour aller
chercher le dialecte de l'époque et de
et de la région donc c'était très
important de de montrer ce film à la
jeunesse algérien d'ailleurs y en a eu
beaucoup et ça a marché on devait faire
une tournée de deux trois villes donné
on s'est retrouvé à presque toutes les
toute la journée l'algérie de long large
et d'une rechute et voilà un an que -
souhait c'est que ce film sorte de des
frontières et qu'ils puissent être vus
alors vous parler d'un film très
pédagogique gilles manceron est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas se servir de ce genre de
film basé sur des faits historiques
notamment pour enseigner cette histoire
dont on dit qu'elle est peu enseignée en
france qu'elle reste encore marginal
c'est vrai que le cinéma joue un grand
rôle dans la diffusion de la
connaissance il ya heureusement un
certain nombre de productions comme
celle là qui éclairent l'histoire et
effectivement il faut s'en servir dans
le travail
d'enseignement de de l'école pour
apprendre l'histoire correctement quand
conformément aux faits aux faits réels
alors karim yahiaoui j'aimerais vous
poser une question sur sur la bataille
d'alger c'est un film culte qui est même
visionné par l'armée américaine qui est
un peu un cas d'école sur la lutte de la
guérilla urbaine ce film a longtemps été
censuré en france il a connu une courte
sortie en 71 puis a été censuré jusqu'en
2004 pourquoi cette censure jusqu'en
2015 c'est un film c'est vrai culte et
très rapidement il a été censuré dès
1966 il est tout de même sorti en salles
en 1970 dans un petit cinéma du quartier
latin mais face au tollé que ça a
provoqué chez les rapatriés d'algérie
notamment face à la violence même que ça
engendre et puisque en 1971 il une
diffusion dans un cinéma parisien mais
les exploitants de salles ont dû
renoncer parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
tentait de diffuser le film il y avait
des vitrines cassées des violences et
film finalement il faudra attendre 2003
c'est le pentagone qui diffusait ce film
parce qu'il y avait un aspect qui les
intéressait tout particulièrement de la
torture et justement ça a provoqué un
tollé aux états unis ce qui a provoqué
la sortie du film aux états unis et dans
la foulée la sortie du film en france
d'abord à cannes en 2004 avant qu'il
soit diffusé dans un certain nombre de
sales donc il a fallu attendre de très
nombreuses années avant de pouvoir
visionner ce film dans les salles
obscures françaises on voit en tout cas
quel point ça reste compliqué de traiter
de ce sujet on va à présent s'arrêter
sur un autre dossier un dossier qui n'a
cessé de hanter les mémoires blessés de
la guerre d'algérie c'est ainsi que
l'historien benjamin stora avait
qualifié le tabou des disparus de la
guerre dans le rapport qu'il a remis à
emmanuel macron en janvier 2021 comme le
mathématicien maurice audin ils ont été
arrêtés à leur domicile par les forces
de l'ordre françaises depuis leurs
familles ont perdu leurs traces plus de
60 ans après elle ne cesse de chercher
les corps de leurs proches dans l'espoir
de faire enfin leur deuil reportage de
nariman laouadi et de karim rihaoui
[Musique]
c'est mon père
je me souvienne de lui de quelqu'un qui
était très aisément
mes enfants encore quelque chose de lui
mais je ne sais pas où il est
le 30 novembre 1957 j'avais septembre
mon père a été pris à 5 heures du matin
on n'avait pas le droit de sortir de la
chambre on était resté dans nos lits 8h
9h toujours rien parvenu 10h et puis ma
mère nous envoie en ville et ne dépend
pas écouté allez voir vos ongles et
dites leur que votre père est sorti ce
matin 6 heures avec des policiers en
civil qui le connaissait surtout qu'il
le connaissait mais il est toujours pas
de retour et ce qu'ils savent quelque
chose qu'on avait été voir un de mes
oncles
qui nous avait dit ah bah écoutez il est
pas seul ils sont 17 à la même heure
c'était pour un contrôle et puis plus
rien
plus rien plus rien plus rien
on a vécu des années très très difficile
surtout enfants
moi j'avais 7 ans j'avais des filles qui
me disait ah oui mais moi aussi mon père
il a été mis en prison il est resté cinq
ans
j avais tu l'as toujours ton père
même s'il est resté cinq ans même s'il
est resté dix ans tu l'as tu ne peux pas
vous parler à moi alors qu'ils me
disaient oui mon père il a été tué par
l'ouest dans la rue oui mais tu l'as vu
mort qu'il a vu enterré ce que tu peux
pas te comparer c'est pas la même chose
on se pose des questions il est on il
est où ce amical je sais qu'il reviendra
jamais ça m'est égal dans fun day il est
où
puis longtemps savais que tu étais
arrivé à des milliers d'algériens mais
on ne connaissait guère qu'une seule
histoire véritablement c'est celle de
maurice audin les militaires le savez
ces colonisés algérien qui n'était pas
comme maurice audin des européens ayant
des relations des relais d'opinion en
métropole personne ne les contraigne
passerait par pertes et profits grâce à
une archive que j'ai découverte aux
archives nationales d'outre-mer en 2018
on a eu la possibilité d'enquêter sur un
certain nombre de cas un gros millier de
gens dans ton c'est parce que les
familles les ont recherché auprès de la
préfecture d'alger quelles ont été
enlevés par l'armée on utilise le terme
dans les ventes de la marque et pas
d'arrestation parce que ça ne ressemble
en rien à une arrestation
ordinaire quand vous savez qu'à tout
moment
peuvent débouler chez vous des
parachutistes peuvent venir vous prendre
vous emporter dans un lieu secret faire
de mousse qu'ils veulent donc y compris
vous torturer on le sait très vite que
la torture est systématique et vous
assassinez et bien par par capillarité
par par diffusion
c'est toute la population visée
potentiellement viser c'est à dire toute
la population qu'on appelait musulmane
d'alger qui a peur
ici on a les derniers cas documentés
donc les derniers cas pour lesquels on a
ajouté de la documentation et on se rend
compte du coût que c'est des sommes
parfois très jeune le plus jeune on le
très jeune élu en photo le pape non un
peu plus tôt
donc lui c'est le plus jeune de tous il
a été enlevé le 14 juin 1957 on continue
de chercher on continue à évaluer
documents par documents et informations
par informations avec le risque que dans
beaucoup de cas on n'avance pas sur la
connaissance précise de chaque cas mais
avec l'idée que en avançant on va mieux
connaître le déroulement collectif le
déroulement pour l'ensemble dans
certains cas on arrive finalement un peu
à ce qui est déjà la connaissance de la
famille c'est à dire ceux selon toute
vraisemblance la personne est morte sous
la torture où elle a été assassiné son
corps a été camouflés où son corps a été
détruite mais ça ne va pas nous indiquer
ce qui compterait vraiment beaucoup pour
la famille et qui serait de savoir
exactement où comment qu'est ce qu'on a
fait en réalité du corps de la personne
[Musique]
je m'appelle loi ou samir là il s'agit
donc d'une recherche qui concerne mon
oncle joie au rabais a enlevé en 1958
avec plusieurs autres personnes par
l'armée française je suis très ému alors
que je les ai jamais connu c'est parce
que j'ai vu en fait
entendu les pleurs de mon père quand il
regardait un peu le le portrait de mon
oncle en visant
puis parti tu m'as laissé tout seul même
si totalité aux années je pense que mon
père a beaucoup souffert après
l'indépendance il a beaucoup beaucoup
chercher son frère et à chaque fois
qu'on me disait qu'il y avait un
charnier quelque part donc dans
notamment à l'est du côté des oreilles
si tout ça on l'appelait pour à
l'identifier l'éventuel dépôt de cendres
demande pas de
depardon on est tous ces trucs là ça
c'est pas important qu'est ce que ça va
nous rapporter tout ce que je demande
c'est vraiment où est la dépouille oui
où il a été mis il a été enterré où il a
été jeté j'en sais rien c'est tout
dsk pouvoir vraiment pour moi un jour me
dire voilà j'ai réussi à trouver où se
trouve mon oncle où il est enterré sinon
je transmettrai à des enfants à mes
neveux et nièces qui peut-être un jour
reprendre et le flambeau mais en moins
moi j'aurais pas avancer comme je
pouvais
[Musique]
où
ans
il
alors gilles manceron vous êtes d'accord
avec ce que dit benjamin stora c'est un
dossier qui n'a cessé de hanter les
mémoires blessés de la guerre d'algérie
oui bien entendu cette question des
disparitions de des interrogations sur
l'emplacement des corps
l'absence d'informations à ce sujet
c'est vraiment une une préoccupation qui
tenaille les descendants et qui pèse sur
les mémoires et je crois que le site
mille autres points or qu'on voit dans
ce petit film
fait oeuvre utile
en essayant de rassembler le maximum de
documents même si on sera pas tout même
si souvent on ne saura pas
l'endroit précis des de la bande dans
des corps mais ça fait rien ça ça
contribue à satisfaire les attentes des
familles de disparus alors karim ce
dossier des disparus que vous avez sur
lequel vous avez travaillé également
s'ajouter à un autre sur lequel vous
avez réalisé un documentaire celui des
essais nucléaires de reggane encore un
dossier qui n'avance pas 73 c'est un
excellent dossier épineux et c'est vrai
que du côté algérien on demande encore
aujourd'hui les cartes 2d
d'enfouissement des déchets nucléaires
qui ont été abandonnés par par la france
notamment du côté de reggane alors il
faut aussi souligner que ces essais
nucléaires ont continué après la
signature des accords d'évian puisque
c'était une des choses qui a été négocié
par les par les français pouvoir
continuer ses essais jusqu'en 1966 ils
ont d'abord été atmosphérique notamment
du côté de reggane gerboise bleue
tristement célèbre et ensuite il ya eu
des essais souterrains qui parfois ont
mal tourné alors aujourd'hui un certain
nombre d'historiens se battent pour
obtenir des archives il ya aussi depuis
2010 une loi qui permet à ceux qui
auraient pâti de ces essais nucléaires
de demander à être indemnisés un certain
nombre d'appelés français ont réussi de
très haute lutte à obtenir des
indemnisations parfois très très faible
beaucoup ont péri avant d'y parvenir les
algériens en théorie ont le droit
d'accéder à 7 à cette possibilité d'être
indemnisé mais beaucoup d'entre eux ne
sont pas au courant on exige un certain
nombre de documents les militaires
avaient leurs carnets militaires il
avait aussi les traces des des courriers
qu'ils envoyaient à leur famille côté
algérien très peu de personnes ont pu
documenter en quelque sorte leur
présence sur tel ou tel lieu mais en
tout cas beaucoup d'entre eux de ce
qu'ils sont malades sont persuadés que
c'est intimement liés à ces essais
nucléaires on écoute quelques quelques
témoignages recueillis du côté de
reygades
on a
ça comme l'allemagne
ou encore l'italie en amical
lé l'air
tellement de la school
je vous disais les historiens temps de
retrouver un certain nombre d'éléments
on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps
de l'ouverture des archives mais les
essais nucléaires ne sont pas concernés
par ces ouvertures d arcy chili et
certaines associations comme l'icann qui
a reçu a réussi à obtenir des dossiers
mais lorsqu'on ouvre ses dossiers il y a
des pages blanches ou des pages qui sont
sous le sceau du secret confidentiel est
donc finalement ça reste très compliqué
d'obtenir des informations sur sur ces
sur ses essais nucléaires pourtant il ya
eu énormément de tests qui ont été faits
à l'époque par par les militaires
français pour savoir le taux de décide
dissémination notamment lors des essais
souterrains mais toutes ces informations
on considère qu'on ne peut pas
les données alors les associations
explique qu' il n'est pas question ici
d'obtenir les secrets de la bombe
atomique mais simplement obtenir des
informations pour savoir quant à
l'étendue des dégâts sur les hommes mais
aussi sur l'environnement merci beaucoup
karim pour pour 7,7 cet éclairage sur ce
dossier qui reste encore encore ouverts
après son indépendance l'algérie était
qualifié de mecs des révolutions les
black panthers jusqu'au che guevara ils
sont nombreux à avoir foulé le sol
algérien nelson mandela avait même dit
c'est l'algérie qui m'a fait homme
le héros sud africain organisé à partir
de 1962 les premiers camps
d'entraînement de la branche armée de la
haine c'est pour lutter contre
l'apartheid nos correspondants en
afrique du sud ont retrouvé un ancien
combattant qui a été informée 100
portraits signés caroline dumas stéphane
carstens
nous l'avons retrouvé dans son village
du limpopo
voilà l'un des premiers membres de la
branche militaire de l' insee qui avait
été formé par nelson mandela en 1961
c'est mon père mais en fait c'est mon
héros
dans la famille mots là bas rares sont
les hommes qui ont survécu dans leur
combat contre l'apartheid
il y avait 17 ans quand il a rejoint l'
insee en
1963 le parti d'envoi s'entraîner en
algérie
[Musique]
vous savez avec l'algérie on a appris
tellement de choses on nous a enseigné
les techniques de guérilla tant en
milieu rural qu'en milieu urbain ces
gens-là nous entraîner nous éduquer et
puis aussi il ne comprenez pas l'anglais
alors ont travaillé avec des interprètes
qui nous aider
l'algérie accueillait alors tous les
combattants d'afrique australe en bien
au mozambique 1 par exemple c'est nelson
mandela qui avait tout organisé il avait
été invité à alger en 1962 par le
président ben bella est fait avec le
ministre de la défense le colonel houari
boumédiène
tous les camps d'entraînements ont été
planifiés se souvient très bien de tout
ça nous a même livré un petit secret
baum a gun boumédiène mandela sand et là
je me souviens il a oublié ses bottes
ses bottes militaires sont restés en
algérie ils nous avaient dit qu'ils les
renverrait je ne sais pas c'est il
arrivé au bo demande tous debout sauf
mandela l'ex combattons étaient séduits
par l'algérie socialiste de l'époque
déçu que ses idéaux révolutionnaires
n'existe plus pas mal en afrique du sud
les fondateurs de ce mouvement de
libération ils sont inquiets la
corruption les gens qui ont des postes
importants exploite ceux qui n'ont rien
le camarade mots là bas et écrit ses
mémoires elle s'intitule nous ne nous
sommes pas battus pour ça
voilà pour ce joli portrait je suis sûr
que notre correspondante caroline dumay
enquêtera sur les bottes de nelson
mandela ou dès que nous saurons plus sur
ses bottes évidemment nous vous
donnerons des informations alors gilles
manceron pourquoi l'algérie a tant
inspiré à cette époque alors ça a été
une grande lutte pour faire respecter le
droit des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
et elle a été victorieuse elle a obtenu
gain de cause et je trouve que la
comparaison avec l'afrique du sud qui
est présent dans votre film
et par mais particulièrement pertinente
et je relève qu' il y a des points
communs le fait d'envisager la lutte
armée et pas uniquement la lutte à mais
la lutte politique dans des proportions
différentes selon les moments et c'est
enfin les deux ont été dans l'un et
l'autre cas envisagé et puis par
ailleurs une grande différence qui
explique bien des choses y compris ce
qui s'est passé à la fin avec le départ
des européens d'algérie alors que les
européens d'afrique du sud sont restés
ça a été l'émergence en afrique du une
sur le tard d'une force politique qui a
accepté le principe un homme une voix
alors que les européens d'algérie
se sont campés sur l'idée algérie
française
inégalités non partage du droit de vote
avec les algériens autochtones selway ce
qui a prédominé même si dans parmi ces
européens il y avait des des voix
minoritaires différente de celle là
c'est quand même le s qui a prévalu et
il n'y a pas eu de force favorable au
dialogue avec les indépendantistes
algériens c'est une grande différence et
s'explique notamment les drames qui se
sont passés à l'été 62 avec le départ
des européens d'algérie notamment avec
le massacre d'oran qu'on a
malheureusement pas eu le temps
d'évoquer c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale du journal de l'afrique
consacré aux 60 ans de l'indépendance de
l'algérie merci à vous d'avoir été sur
ce plateau pour en parler merci aux
équipes en régie et à notre chef
d'édition coeliaque arras et lens
[Musique]